and ladies and gentlemen here we are
from timcast.com elon musk successfully
buys twitter twitter's board reached a
deal in the billion dollar bid to sell
tesla ceos uh tesla to sell to tesla's
ceo and take the company private do you
know what happens on thursday guys
you tell me freedom tunes uploads a new
cartoon twitter's earnings report oh
well
and what do you think that earnings
report would show
something good or something bad
bad something bad because twitter's been
struggling for some time you look at any
news story over the past several months
and they say twitter is lagging not
reaching its goals which means
i'm willing to bet elon musk played some
4d chess he knew the earnings report was
coming up and he knew he had to act now
he offered 54 dollars and 20 cents per
share
if on thursday news comes out that the
earnings were not good the stock would
likely fall the board knows this they
know what their earnings are if they
rejected a 54.20 offer
knowing that their stock would be worth
half that by thursday they would be
liable for damages for not adhering to
their fiduciary duty to the shareholders
and that could be what 20 billion
dollars if the earnings report came out
and the stock dropped to 40 or 30 bucks
the board's like nah i don't want to be
responsible for that money i don't want
to be sued for that just give him the
deal done we'll see what the investors
say we'll see what this means but i
think elon elon musk
he cornered them masterfully their uh
their main source of their earnings as
far as i can tell is ad revenue uh it's
a very risky
proposition for a company to roll that
die because
if the advertisers get disenfranchised
or disgruntled they'll pull their their
money which means the twitter's
basically an advertising firm no i call
shenanigans shenanigans
twitter banned ads that deny their their
opinions on climate change
so if twitter is
holding up their duty to their
shareholders they wouldn't
they wouldn't say no to advertisements
on political grounds
twitter outright said we don't want your
money if you if you disagree on climate
science interesting you think they would
try to make the argument that uh you
know taking money from those groups
would limit their ability to make a
profit in the future because they could
damage the reputation i don't think
that's going to work in court i don't
think it's just that i think that they
killed virality they made the site
boring because the board of directors
represents other companies which feels
like twitter is worth more to them dead
than alive
and so what you've got as a twitter
that's dead under their reign elon's
like
this company is worth a lot to me alive
it's worth a lot to me
if i can bring back the excitement of
viral content that comes from twitter
when it was a free marketplace of ideas
and my only regret about all of this is
that i don't get to take that ride with
elon musk anymore
because shareholders were all going to
get bought out and he's taking it
private yes full disclosure i have 22
shares
through my brokerage app when elon musk
announced he bought it i was like all
right i opened my account i had a
thousand bucks and i clicked buy and i
think i'll end up making like 100 bucks
yeah not bad thanks elon i will i will
buy a delicious umami burger so what
you're saying is that this show is
funded by elon musk this is propaganda
you've just acknowledged it we've lost
all credibility it costs 100
per 10 years per decade to run this
that's all it is and you know that
hundred dollars funds everything no i
think um
i think twitter is not upholding its
fiduciary duty they banned political ads
why
they banned anti-climate change ads why
i i get it you might disagree with it
but why would a for-profit company say
we don't want money from legitimate
advertisers
yeah because they're playing politics
they were using their ads as a political
statement probably this this one just
happened too and i was kind of like do i
need to sue over this because i got to
tell you man that one
like when they announced that they were
banning political ads
i'm like okay there's a potential
there's a potential argument here they
could say in order to maintain the
health of the platform and i don't mean
their kind of health i mean like people
using the platform we don't want to be
dominated by just big spatterings of
political ads the money would actually
cause more damage the ads would the
climate change thing makes no sense
conservatives would love it yeah like
and the left would hate it no i hear you
on that i'm just curious if it's an
argument that they would make if they
would say something like if people see
advertisements from these groups we're
going to lose our credibility as a
website and i get that but but a judge
is going to be like except 80 plus
million people in this country yeah
agree with those ads
or people are swayed by those it's not
an argument like you could you could
imagine them arguing oh man you know
millennials don't like drinking soda you
know this this is actually true
millennials don't drink soda so those
coca-cola ads are really bad for our
credibility
i mean
sure
but i'm not going to blame you know
downtown chicago for the ad that gets
put up on the billboard off the highway
that's ridiculous
i feel like this uh there's still like a
it's a 12 year old business model
they're still running off of advertising
which is like very 2010. they have an
opportunity to spin up a utility token
um to streamline f activity on the
website where you could spend one
twitter token to get a thousand views on
twitter like mines does that's another
revenue model you could have direct to
subscriber
uh
uh payments which like your subscribers
could pay you directly as a user of
twitter twitter could take like one
percent
and then that could be a new revenue
model for the site dogecoin tips
oh my gosh yeah now that musk is
involved well i'll ask you guys would
you be willing to pay for twitter i do
notice about this you do yeah so you
wouldn't what about you i'm not but who
knows i think elon musk is going to be
very imaginative about offering premium
features that i would actually want i
think a big issue for conservatives or
just people who are not you know
speaking the company line on twitter is
like why would i bother spending any
money when it's obvious
that this site
does what they can to throttle what i
say on here and i think it's a common
perception of twitter
and you know i think if nothing else
elon musk is going to at least
make it transparent and have some
consistent policies and say you know
you're getting throttled because of this
algorithm or you got banned because of
this policy and be like okay that's fair
you know and maybe even provide ways to
remedy that to be so people can get
reinstated but you know it's like we've
seen so many people who acted in good
faith and had good arguments and were
like really good viral accounts um that
got banned because some passive
aggressive nitwit and behind the scenes
just decided i don't like this guy i'm
banning them alex jones that's obvious
project veritas and james o'keefe very
obvious
carl benjamin aka sargon of akkad
also obvious i miss him every day on
twitter and then you've got the of
course milo yiannopoulos laura loomer
who who else the president of the united
i states the trump the trump one is a
special class and i get it of itself
like i'm i was just trying to name
people like who are the obviously trump
libs of tick or not libs um babylon b i
think oh yeah
that supposedly is the reason he decided
to buy twitter i don't agree but that
was like the
the straw that broke the camel's back
carpe donctum
carpe donctum was for those under
familiar a meme smith who just made
memes and uh was banned for literally no
reason
none
you know then you have all the people
that were posting like interesting
vaccine facts you know and that just
went against the company line they did
their research and everything and i was
like you're banned because we believe
the vaccine is safe for most people even
the disclaimer was like
safe for most people what does that mean
unsafe for a lot of people that's the
really good way to lawyer the answer you
can't say
it wasn't even about that i mean
anything that could come from a doctor
if the doctor disagreed with some doctor
twitter chooses like we can't live this
way we can't live in a world where big
tech is like here's the approved doctors
and their opinions right i can
understand the idea of of consensus in
that there are a lot of people and and
the majority of research looks in this
direction
but it's just an insane way to live
where we say
we will actually ban dissenting opinion
that's the opposite of science so
my point ultimately here
when it comes to
trump when it comes to alex jones when
it comes to miley annopolis when it
comes to laura loomer these people did
nothing illegal they were banned because
they did things that twitter did not
like
if elon is to restore free speech all of
these people get reinstated well this is
a long conversation i don't think that
having one authoritarian give the
company to another authoritarian to make
the decision necessarily means free
speech because if it's if we're relying
on elon's good faith to unban people and
then he still retains the right to ban
anybody at any time if he sells the
company or something happens to him
someone else takes over this it's just
exactly where it was so it might look
like free speech but really you need to
get that get rid of that code you need
that code to be he said he wants to open
source the algorithms right and that's
the big issue to me i don't think the
unbanning is even going to be number one
it's going to be make the code
transparent hunt down all these bot
farms because i think that's the big
thing you know you post anything
you know i was talking about the torture
of joe biggs in in federal prison and
you get people saying he deserves to be
tortured because he's an insurrectionist
i'm like who are you oh bought
a27z5 you know like get off of my
timeline what are you doing here you
know i developed a whole algorithm for
it at ron437.org
naah it's like how can you tell if
something is a bot new automated
uh
anonymous and hostile those that's the
the algorithm and they all fit the mold
and they're just twitter is full of them
and and people that's what's making
twitter boring i'm not here to argue
with bots i want to argue with real
people i want to discuss with real
people that's what elon wants to do he
wants to make it so that um and i think
this was his proposal five dollars a
month for twitter blue when you get
verified i agree with it that's
absolutely i have mixed feelings because
that just feels like a pay-to-play model
that if if the five bucks yeah if the
u.s government wants to find a thousand
people that are going to tow the line
and give them all five bucks a month to
do it it does those people aren't more
valid than me who doesn't feel like
paying the money
he says everybody human is going to have
the chance to get verified but it's the
humans that are getting paid by like a
nefarious actor to be there that i
wonder like how is that gonna make them
seem more valued because they spent five
bucks the bots aren't a human you can
have one human manning like a hundred
different accounts and that's what's
happening and so my joke is like there's
either a dnc or pentagon office
somewhere where somebody's running all
of these but then you're talking about
having them verify their actual
personality with like a social security
number or an address which is extremely
dangerous to centralize that data or an
id yeah if you centralize that data on a
on some database people from all around
the world can seize it and sell it and
to find out where you live and what what
your credit card information is but that
argument
you're arguing that i mean every single
website does that
i've been looking into what's called
decentralized identity there's ways for
you to have an identity online that
isn't necessarily sure but let's let's
keep the context of twitter because what
you're saying is just some idea of
something that might happen but elon is
doing nothing different from literally
any other website um i identify you
trade crypto you got to verify your
identity to trade crypto i worry about
some of those websites frankly that's
because there's a financial incentive
like with mines too you can spend money
with like mines plus so that you're able
to send the mines tokens off the network
onto your own personal wallet so there's
a financial value to spending money per
month right but if it's just to show
everyone that you're you're realistic i
don't think you have to understand what
your argument against elon musk is
though it sounds like you're saying the
internet itself has a problem
is not my is not a solution to
verification i can't it doesn't vary but
let's let's let's say he goes for the
humans get verified model if you're if
you're human you can choose verification
that's originally twitter verification
was to prove you weren't a robot
because they were robot accounts and
they were like you can verify that and
if someone what makes a parody account
or whatever you have you're in crossland
it's your image you've verified it yeah
it's to keep popular accounts from
getting um
mimicked or you know fake accounts no no
the original the original purpose was
just to prove you were a real person to
prove you were the person behind the
account it had nothing to do with
stopping mimicry uh or or imitation or
anything like that
eventually they said we can't scale this
up so they gave up they said we're not
going to verify people anymore we're
closing verification requests it's only
going to be for the celebrities we
choose because we don't want to deal
with it this led to a huge backlash
where people are like verifications of
badge of like authenticity twitter you
get special features when you're
verified that other people don't get run
for office that'll get you verified or
work for a major corporation you can
make that phone call so one of the
things you want to do is you can be
verified good and then i'll just be like
verified accounts only please i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna argue with an
account with one follower that's like
the 80th account some guy's running
because he bought 10 phones to do it or
a company or some like some what was
that what was that democrat company that
did sock puppies
i'm not gonna we'll avoid naming them
for for legality reasons but
you've got political firms
that will hire one guy to run 50
accounts and pretend to be 50 people to
try and sway public opinion to harass
you get rid of all of that that'll make
the platform healthier absolutely and
you can tell who the bots are because
they're all coming from the same ip
address this is what i said like let's
look at what the ip address of some of
these
bots are i mean we don't have to make it
fully transparent but
you know elon and the engineers at
twitter can take a look at that it
shouldn't be that hard to notice who the
bots are that way there's two like um i
guess
ethos of of running social media there's
real identity real id where they can
like track you down to them to the way
you poop in the day and then there's
anonymous id where they have no idea who
you are and they're both valuable like
if you have a totalitarian regime and
you're on twitter they're going to know
exactly where you are and what you're
saying they'll find you and get you but
if you have anonymous accounts you're
able to have a revolution against a
corrupted establishment
um
you don't have to be verified yeah i was
going to say isn't it possible to not be
verified but i mean i'm saying i'm not
forcing you to verify if i'm not
verified you're going to set yours so
that you can only get responses from
people that are there's going to be
people that aren't verified that don't
want to play that game and spend that
money and then there's going to be like
nobodies that are getting the government
agencies paying their five dollars a
month that are going to seem like valid
or so that's the thing about politics
you find very quickly if you want to
have an opinion you got to step up and
stand up for yourself if i'm out in the
in in public and i see a bunch of people
wearing masks all yelling things i will
hold their opinion to less value than
someone standing up with with identity
revealed i understand the value of
anonymity for that reason depending on
the things people are talking about i
respect people's right to it but if i
know who you are i know what's behind
you i know what you stand for and why i
have more reason to trust you i'm a huge
advocate of people making videos for
that reason because you cannot fake it
when you make a video they see your face
they see your mouth get out of the text
in general that's i've been talking
about this since 2006 so i'm fully on
board with getting behind your own words
but there are times and places where
it's very dangerous and i i don't think
those people should be shut out of the
conversation well but also wait a couple
years on the video front man that
stuff's getting easier and easier to
fake
i agree ian but what you're saying is
it's it's it's preference now if
somebody wants to distribute an
anonymous uh pamphlet or something you
can still do it the people who are
sharing the founding fathers ideas were
doing it as themselves but the ideas
behind it were under pen names or
pseudonyms so no one knew who was
actually writing it but people were
sharing it they weren't posting it as
like anime characters i mean look i
interact with plenty of anonymous
accounts you know but they act in good
faith they make good arguments you know
and and so i listen to them and that's
been the interesting thing about twitter
is there is a sort of natural prestige
system where people who make interesting
insights honest statements
you know that are valuable their
engagement goes up their followers go up
and they become
you value their opinion more than some
random who comes in and calls you a
poopy ass question should titanium
mcgrath be verified
oh if you don't know who that is it's a
fake person tatiana tatiana
you would need a policy on that titania
is the name of the fairy from the uh
from what story was that from midsummer
night
that's an interesting concept i mean is
is uh yeah it would be a legit but it
would be a legitimate parody site and
you want to like
it's not
huh it's not a website so i'd say no
well no but there could be imitators
would i don't know it's just something
to think about i mean do fictional
characters ever get check marks on
twitter to verify that it's an official
account i guess mickey mouse or
something is making it interesting yeah
let me look into that disney trademark
properties thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there